we boarded eight to eight
you know what a tortured life-changing
Journey we are about to embark on
now we're finally at the end
like it or not that
adding the rest of the
world's glow is back I didn't ask for
any of this so none of us asked for any
of this I wish I could tell you
everything that's gonna happen man tell
me if I tell you about the few
[Music]
God has chosen me to guide the worthy
through the final judgment
Angelino capable of projecting as anyone
should be heading
it is my duty to bring on the end of
times
[Music]
just find Angelina and stop her
[Applause]
this is it we have no more time if
anybody can rally the troops as you
we've been given an opportunity
reminder of what's most important
it's time to be with the people you love
hold them tight
we're connected cow
tomorrow
might be all we've got
[Music]
thank you
Wyoming Game and Fish Department I'm a
little worried about Joe
he went looking for a missing Hunter and
now he's missing too
something is happening on that mountain
so homicide I want no other information
shared we've got to be kidding me
get rid of him shouldn't you be in the
hospital
someone hunted a hunter three matching
poke chips at three crime scenes this is
the work of serial killer
Joe Pickett what took you so long you
either tell me what you know with
another innocent person is going to die
the person who killed this Hunter should
be celebrated
Klamath more anti-hunting activist and
his Cult of crazies are riding on the
streets
two the killer has gotten us nowhere
what about why pick at least he can do a
cop's job
drop your weapons stand out
no one trusts a lone man in a while
you're the American dream
Rags to Riches
trailers to mansions
[Applause]
you are [__] jostling
[Music]
just to you
easy I'll just do that
[Music]
I'm telling you right now these people
in here are gauging whether or not you
still got it
I just wonder about the strippers
they're kind of out femming her with the
flips and the dips and the
Gaga
you're too distracted
to block off all the noise
I'm sorry who are you
nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
do you feel this right now
oh no thank you
[Music]
I think I just fell in love with you
what does that mean he's taking over the
house he's brainwashed her
Not a Human Being
you're a star
never trust a dude with a rat tail
[Music]
when did you first learn your friend was
missing
three schools in three years didn't even
finish your junior year at the last
place
I've already told you like 10 times is
that all you've got on me sheriff for
now trouble seems to follow you wherever
you go
I thought you were coming I want to but
you never do it's our last High School
summer last time to be officially stupid
our exchange student arrives today tell
me why you thought this was such a great
idea
to become close friends
[Music]
we were going to get in so much trouble
this winter break oh yeah it was gonna
be the best two weeks
[Applause]
I'm hunting myself to make sure I'm not
dreaming
well lucky that I came along and
corrupted you so the best friend I could
ever ask for my ultimate ride or die
ride or die
[Music]
they know who it is
people are gonna start asking questions
we have to get our story straight
I've just received information that
shares a whole new light on things
that's what happened to happen if she
never came into town
[Music]
just lay low everything's gonna be okay
I am done making excuses for you you
pushed me past my Breaking Point really
Megan
[Music]
you have no idea what this might cost
our family
I hate seeing you like this but I need
to know what happened and what if you
don't like what you hear
you ever wish you could go back
just undo something
[Music]
I soak myself on that stage
and when you visualize something very
clearly you believe that you 100 can get
there
there was a lot of things they had to
learn
obstacles that they had to overcome
you can get an injury then all your
athletic stuff is over but the only
thing that no one can take from you is
your mind Arnold Schwarzenegger
terminated as box office competition I
was looking for another challenge
politics
let's get to work
he had no staff no real plan makeup
please he blew up the political system
problems and problems but I want to do
the things that everyone calls
impossible
people will remember my successes and
they were also remember those failures
it was very tough on my marriage and my
relationship with the kids
that have caused enough pain for my
family I'm gonna have limited the rest
of my life
why did you give up
well because my vision didn't talk about
giving up my vision was climbing that
mountain
[Music]
is the guy who turns his boat towards
the torpedo
if you're always hungry you're never
really satisfied
no matter what it takes work your ass
off
do it
do it now
[Music]
is this a bathroom it's definitely yes
that's a bathroom you never told me we
had a toilet it's not a good one we
fishing cans Charlie what's the first
word that comes to your mind to describe
us subtle what are you doing
classy
you guys do understand what inflation is
yeah yes absolutely yeah but for the
sake of argument yeah
pretend we don't we are interested in
featuring your bar on our show sounds
kind of cool what the hell are you doing
I don't know if I want to be on a show
where they make us look jerks the Cooter
is most likely on fire from a yeast
infection go in the bathroom rinse it
out and be better next time I'd hate if
they like edited it like make me look
dumb or something
why is it going off my stomach because
you have a belly full of nickels nice
It might smell a little funky in here Mr
Malcolm I did vomit in his car earlier
oh perfect
[Music]
I've broken every single bone in my hand
I'm going to scream now because I can't
hold it in so here we go
now who's ready to talk murder we have
to wake up to murders every morning
they're talking about the serial killer
that's like basically in our backyard it
is so exciting
L.A it's brutal especially when you're
pushing 50. bartenders into you that's
like it'd be bartender's dad did anyone
catch my favorite murder
spoilers no hey what do you even know
about should I use protection or should
he just pull out you know if I end up on
Dateline I can leave a massive DNA Trail
for you True Crime weirdos
can't pay any of our bills and you just
lost your job we have a baby on the way
so tell me how are we going to get by
she is the victim of the West Side
Ripper it's him
I know my Killers but if we make a
podcast about this together we could
bring them in on it bring the killer in
or what the podcast we force them to do
it oh my God this is gonna change our
lives
no one ever went broke betting on
America's obsession with murder he'll
never hurt anyone ever again or we go to
the cops let's do this babe you're so
hot for the baby says actually pull my
hair come on baby
are you in danger
you really think he's gonna kill us
well you know about the west side rip We
Are In Too Deep this is it we're gonna
have a baby in jail we
do next
no I'm hiding something I love it are
you crazy
[Applause]
you want to come visit me in San Quentin
Midnight Express me under the table what
is that you know look like you're
sweeping I don't do that come on bad
behavior
daddy do you know why you're here I have
these blank spots
sometimes I think that night marked me
everything that came afterwards
[Music]
couldn't be a coincidence could it
brought in a kid last night it might be
something that interests you
daddy you don't really seem like a
dangerous person can you tell me how you
ended up here
loser hey I'm gonna kick your little
wiry ass
[Music]
no no
you want to come in clean yourself up
you are safe now you never struck you as
strange that this man just showed up to
save you
I figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky
no
there's glass everywhere signs of a
struggle Blood on the floor what about
the girl don't sign a hurry either I'm
thinking that he officer
this wasn't a random shooting he's
hiding something
what happened in that house where did
they all go
we have these blank spots
they're not the only people close to you
to disappear are they do you think these
are all victims
can you see how all of this can seem
like it was you wait do you think that
I'm the one pulling the strings
what if I said I do I'm not
Danny I'm trying to help you I didn't
shoot anybody his best interest is to
plead guilty they're all in this
together if I'm right Danny may be
innocent what are you not telling me
what are you not telling yourself
[Music]
I like believe in love okay
I'm Emmy your new Love Bug nothing
personal we're just not big on love
right Sarah yeah I love so complicated
and messy
hey if you're mad then why did you do
the sexiest possible thing to me
Paul Crum horn his wife of nearly 40
years is gone
I feel kind of weird it's called getting
horny glory is that you oh you'll Scamp
I haven't seen you in forever how are we
[__] Evelyn today for the love of God
Maury read your clients files
Dante out
[Music]
the world is trash
[Applause]
and physical violence
I plan to become a shame wizard shut the
door I'm burning us all up that actually
went better than I thought it would yes
but my office is burning
everything is hopeless
I know how scary it is hope disappears
oh yeah but hate can't protect you
[Music]
what's up tell us you guys talking about
pubes
oh no
by Dante's zombie penis you can't kill a
zombie penis you've got to tame it love
it Like a Daddy are you ready to do that
Pete bear your soul and then kiss the
tip of Dante's penis no
kids I am morally obligated to tell you
you can never reuse a Gundam unless of
course those condoms are Dr mori's
reusable dong sleeves the hog hats so
nice you can junk in them twice
thank you
you're gonna start the engine sometime
soon Erica
100 times during the war
it's like riding a bike
I sense attention the feeling that
something's in the air oh my God
hard job
puts us up against death
not like it but we do have to face it
hold on to your Saddles
we are explorers
it's easy to forget how awesome that is
that's the mission it's what we love
most
we have this crazy Theory I love a crazy
Beauty this is
thank you
know the odds
of all of us being here at this time
it's improbable yet here we are together
surprise
[Music]
live long and prosper Mr Wendler I
thought you could also live in
if you want to watch
I can't really do another True Crime
what about oh my God she even has your
hair
the first question any platform is gonna
ask is what's the hook
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Salma Hayek bingo
how's the coffee duck [__] I did not say
that like that this is an adaptation of
Jones life can everybody that has
streamberry watch this
[Music]
this guy had been adopting people so
that's what your documentary is about
the details are so awful it is
irresistible
I love it
[Music]
the man
is lost
[Music]
and we both feel that you could use a
break
I think I'd like that very much
he got kicked off movie Set weeks ago
Nick's offering 30k for the first photo
ever
half of these [__] would kill
themselves if he didn't take their
picture
this way you stink
[Music]
the fantasy writing down your number I
won't mind
one
it has taken you over
and you must be humble in the face of it
the things they can do
[Music]
you not seen Joan is awful no but it's
on my list
if it ain't the world famous gemstone
Family Central Daddy has taken a step
back there has been a decline in
attendance is this because of the
goddamn shitty poll numbers 85 said
you're colder than an ice cube shoved up
a polar bears [__] I remember the
same poll saying that your songs are
when most people in church go to take a
[__] prove it Jesse
throughout your lives you scared your
kids gonna blow it pretty much you so
hell-bent on running this church the way
your daddy did only problem is you angel
from our largest benefactors is
departing our ministry was to receive
over 200 million dollars it is very bad
news
I'm scared Jesse what if we don't have
what it takes we just have to refuse to
fail how are we going to do that
together
do we have to include Judy even that
[__]
[Music]
these are the brothers tomorrow's fires
this is a militia gemstones and
Montgomery oil and vinegar Fire and Ice
when the end of times come our way to
double that these phony fakers will be
called to the kingdom of heaven
there's a war comes the Lord is picked
out he'll use each of us you know how he
intends to use you
Ministry
Resurrection boy restore the kingdom
[Music]
we have been traveling on has been bumpy
as of lately
somebody needs to make sure everything's
gonna turn out okay you get killed I
promise we will try to avenge you take
care of My Wife and Kids say what what's
up yeah I feel like your kids are old
enough I mean it's a big ask
you know what I mean we don't know what
our schedules are
[Music]
you want to tell me where the hell we're
going
Manhattan
Jesus Christ
can you at least tell me what the hell
you are doing out here a few weeks back
I got raided
they took your kid
have you seen this man goes by the name
of Negan
[Music]
how do I figure into this Maggie
the man who's got her show you know him
you need me
is on the island
[Music]
we don't know you you get on the island
but you don't get off
he makes sure of that it's the real
reason we're here so you want to go to
the cycle that we can help you with
foreign
Danger
ous
Since You've Been Gone
he's gotten much worse
how do you think I came back
[Music]
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
friend
this is personal
very few of us know about the walls
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
do you feel responsible
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight
foreign
this is coming from a place of wanting
to start fresh and clean this is going
to be a destination spot we drafted a
quick term sheet we need more money will
you turn that thing off please how
should that make a new insane
I don't mind it
[Music]
the facelift it's not a gun Baron is a
facelift and a gun
I take six months to open
six months not speaking what confidence
hockey crazy
still thinking chaos menu
yeah chaos menu but um thoughtful
oh gross we need like a reset
I'm trying to start from a place of
positivity
[Music]
be sending you to a culinary School a
hell of a lot of siblings in here don't
look them in the eyes
ideally we need five days on yeah I just
can't do Fridays or Saturdays when can I
talk to the chef you are oh
oh don't freak out and go calling for
Mom Mom
she can't hear you oh that's my love I'm
a supervisor supervisor what
I needed a second
chance
you got this baby yeah
so has your life been brasato
opening a restaurant gotta go hard every
day gotta control the Zone I
still I I love the name you don't
remember the name of course I remember
the name we didn't even tell anybody 100
told me the name how could you remember
the name
you sure says original birth yeah it's a
pretty mistake collector's item
[Music]
can I have seven bing bing Burgers
please
[Applause]
be plenty more where that came from
why are you so damn big bro
get your mind right afterwards As Long
As I push there's no defeats
the world is not ready yet
cause I got Camp breathe in here maybe
it's a rap what key be to lock but we
beat to rap what you've never been out
there just hit the sideshow with us well
I'm a Virgo and Virgo's love Adventure
we showing up with it
welcome to Bing Bang Burger what can I
bop you with today
I'm gonna take my time and get to know
her you just need to look her in the
eyes and say I want you I want you with
my with your eyes don't say that out
loud people are gonna try to use you and
put them on display
you said you'd come from a desolate
place I'm not from a desolate place I'm
from Oakland yes a desolate place and
when they can't use you no more they're
gonna try to get rid of you measure
Threat Level in the [__] monster I need
the people to believe in me when I take
my helmet off I need for myself to pop
so when y'all kicking it tonight tonight
the people love me
you are 13 foot tall black man
Fury
[Music]
the whole thing has to be torn down
damn
Spotlight you're illegally trespassing
how about this mother
[Music]
[Applause]
now
for the first time
I understand real fear
[Music]
geralt
Jennifer
two days ago a Strike Team assassinated
President Udo
and yet you cannot prove that we weren't
involved doesn't that concern you no sir
it terrifies me
you need to manage this Jack yes sir
what are you gonna tell him this
corruption goes way higher than the CIA
hey buddy say welcome I figured we could
use the help wish me luck good luck
give me everything you can I'm Domingo
Chavez
on paper you might be the deadliest
operator the cia's ever employed I need
to find out who's behind all this to be
honest with you you're a live God
see this
now I'm blushing
so what are we getting at convergence
the fusing of a drug cartel with a
terrorist organization
they can move anything humans weapons
suicide bombers unlimited resources
paired with undying hatred
not on my watch
the world is a game board of changing
hands
nothing but vipers Beyond these walls
you do not know who these people are
sure I'll meet him soon enough
Jack is out there risking his life I
always wanted to be a federal alley it's
the CIA was second fourth
Jack where the hell are you
sure you want to know
what do you say he hung up on me typical
everything
[Applause]